this video is part of a collaboration
with life's biggest questions make sure
to check out their video after this
we humans have always been captivated by
the idea of immortality for obvious
reasons
most of us would rather be alive than
dead throughout history immortality has
been relegated to the realm of mythology
or science fiction but as our technology
has advanced some scientists have begun
to consider the possibility of actually
extending a human's life beyond the
death of one's physical body in this
video by life's biggest questions we see
that while it is dangerous humans can
live without a heart for an extended
period of time the same goes for many
other organs in a worst-case scenario
sort of speculation it's thought that
the absolute minimum organ content the
human body could endure would be the
brain part of the lungs with Airways and
blood vessels the heart the liver a
metre or so of the small intestine
called the jejunum part of a kidney bone
marrow and at least part of the chest
skeleton and the diaphragm however
that's without non-biological implants
theoretically everything in that
worst-case scenario could be replaced
with some kind of implant or machine
except for the brain of course with our
current stage of technology a normal
life with all those modifications would
be impossible but that hasn't stopped
people from pursuing the idea and even
more radical hypotheses for example one
Italian surgeon named Sergio canavero
has planned to perform a human head
transplant for several years and has
recently announced that he successfully
performed the operation on two deceased
participants he says that over the
course of an 18 hour surgery he was able
to connect the spine nerves and blood
vessels of a head to those of a separate
body can of arrows next goal is to
perform the surgery on two brain-dead
but living donors followed by a
conscious head donor paralyzed from the
neck down this has drawn a lot of
criticism from skeptics who have
nicknamed the surgeon dr. Frankenstein
but if he does manage to perform a
successful head transplant on a living
patient it would be groundbreaking so
far we've only looked at extending human
life through biological means in the
original body but what if we went even
further even more extreme than a full
head transplant is the idea that one
might transfer just his or her brain
into an artificial body that's something
that sounds like it's straight out of
science fiction so the obvious question
is is it even possible the hesitant
general consensus is probably yes
eventually right now there are a few
main challenges facing would-be brain
swappers first the actual removal of the
brain from a living patient
the brain can survive without oxygen for
about four minutes but any longer than
that and the patient will likely suffer
irreversible damage the surgery would
have to be relatively quick even though
the brain could be chilled and perfused
to extend its viability outside the host
body once the brain is safely out of the
patient's body the next challenge is
reconnecting its inputs and outputs with
the new artificial body these include
the cranial nerves and the entire spinal
cord which would need to somehow
interface with the artificial body to
establish sensory inputs and motor
outputs even if everything goes
perfectly and the brain can function
inside its new shell since the
artificial body is not the brains
natural habitat the connections will
probably not be precise enough to
maintain abilities like speech and other
motor functions even if an adult swapped
their brain into one of these artificial
bodies the brain would have to relearn
all your basic motor functions as if you
were an infant in theory you'd still be
you you'd just be trapped inside your
brain with little to no means of
expressing yourself while your brain
adapts to its new habitat some speculate
that even if the procedure is possible
patients could very likely go insane
before they could adapt another problem
is maintenance the human brain doesn't
exist all by itself
it works by communicating with other
parts of the body information from
organs and chemical exchanges with
spinal fluid and the blood stream allow
for healthy operation scientists would
have to find a way to mimic these
processes artificially which could prove
to be incredibly challenging if not
impossible if it is possible the brain
would likely age as normal defeating
hopes of immortality unless some new
breakthrough in anti-aging technology is
also implemented of course if we do
achieve drastically increased lifespan
through brain swapping we'll have a huge
number of legal and societal changes to
deal with finally the last challenge
would likely be an ethical one when we
hear about a surgeon planning to perform
a total head transplant on two
brain-dead patients our gut reaction is
probably one of a version it just
doesn't sound natural judging by the
fact that dr. assisted suicide is still
illegal in many places it's hard to
believe that allowing someone to remove
your brain from your living body in an
attempt to stick it in a functioning
robotic replacement would be okay but
who knows the medical advancements
needed to perform such a radical
operation are likely still several
decades off who knows where society will
be at that point
what do you think are we headed towards
a future full of robotic superhumans or
will brain swapping remain in the realm
of science fiction let us know what you
think in the comments below if you'd
like to know more about the current
state of living without a heart go visit
our friends over at life's biggest
questions if you haven't already click
the subscribe button to join the second
thought family YouTube doesn't like
recommending videos with touchy topics
which are some of our favorites here on
second thought so if you want to be sure
to get notified every time I release a
new video make sure you click the little
bell next to my channel name finally if
you'd like to watch the rest of my
videos you can binge watch them all by
clicking here thanks for watching and
I'll see you in the next video